[Music]
this is a review of the best styluses
for the most popular tablets the plural
of stylus is actually stylized what do
you know you're not even wearing pants
you just
if you're looking to cartoon take notes
or design you've got lots of options
every year tech companies pitch their
stylists and tablet combos with varying
degrees of rhetorical flourish the
fastest s-pen yeah game-changing
accessory so i really love this pen
which basically all i'm on to them just
saying buy our our stick so i set out to
find the best tablet stylus combo for
mixed use with an emphasis on drawing
tested tablets included the big three a
12.9 inch apple ipad pro the microsoft
surface pro 8 and a samsung galaxy tab
s8 plus i tested styluses for all three
devices sadly you can't mix and match so
no apple pencil on a galaxy tab or
samsung s pen with a microsoft surface
but i did throw in some leading
third-party options for the ipad since
it currently holds the tablet market
share throne
all styluses were evaluated on a few
core pieces of criteria build in comfort
pressure sensitivity and ink flow
and software options
first let's take a look at the styluses
themselves look as a kid i collected
pens
nerd as such i'm snobby about the feel
and weightiness of a stylus when it
comes to the best in-hand experience
it's a horse race between the 129 dollar
apple pencil 2 and 119 microsoft surface
slim pen 2. both feel great are easy to
use for long sessions have magnetic
docking mechanisms and sturdy tactile
replaceable nibs which you can replace
for around twenty dollars where the
surface slim pen inches ahead is with
its more pointed nib and haptic feedback
the slim pen vibrates lightly to emulate
the feel of real paper it takes a second
to get used to but it's pleasant for a
similar experience on the ipad with the
apple pencil 2 i had to purchase a 40
screen protector by paper light which
adds friction and resistance
but like all screen protectors is a pain
to put on
samsung's 60 s pen though innovative
with its soft nibs feels too
insubstantial like something you get to
keep score at putt putt also the nibs
wear down quickly and samsung does not
offer replacements for a larger s pen
experience you can upgrade to the 100 s
pen pro
as for the third party options i like
the feel of the 70 zag it's basically a
clone size wise of the apple pencil too
and the logitech crayon feels solid but
looks like a relative to the pencil
steve used in blue's clues
meanwhile the adana note plus could be
better it feels like something you could
buy with tickets at a mall arcade
and one quick note when stylish shopping
choose one with a flat edge or one that
resembles a carpenter's pencil fully
circular styluses will roll off the
couch or desk into some other abyss for
me the winner for design is a tie
between the apple pencil 2 and the
surface slim pen 2. the best budget and
note-taking option goes to the zag
next let's talk about pressure
sensitivity and palm rejection when it
comes to illustrating pressure
sensitivity is paramount especially for
pressure sensitive brush types and
smooth line transitions only some of the
styluses tested supported pressure
sensitivity those with the feature are
the apple pencil gen 1 and gen 2 the
microsoft surface slim pen 2 the samsung
s pen and the adonit note plus
i'm including the apple pencil gen 1
here because the 329 entry level ipad
only supports the apple pencil one
for drawing i prefer the fine pointed
tips on the apple pencil 2 and microsoft
surface slim pen 2 which offer more of a
pen to paper experience
while the s pen is the most responsive
of any of the options in its own app it
didn't perform consistently across all
apps plus the s pen nib feels a bit more
like a sharpie marker and while the
adonit note plus does have pressure
sensitivity it's spotty at best and
non-functional at worst this is what
happens when you try to connect
you don it
to procreate
none stylus
no
an adonis spokeswoman told me this is
due to procreate currently not
supporting the note plus and then there
are the styluses without pressure
sensitivity these are the options more
suited for handwriting and note taking
on that front the zag led the way with
the logitech crayon too close behind the
top choices 2 all fared incredibly well
when it came to palm rejection
maybe one little errant mark there
overall the apple pencil 2 just edged
out the microsoft surface slim pen 2.
apple's option is slightly more
sensitive to delicate line strokes and
if you're not looking to draw as much
the budget pick again goes to the zag
lastly a stylus is only as good as the
operating system and apps it works with
between windows android and ios app
stores there are dozens of sketching
illustrating design and note-taking apps
after trying some of the top ones i
couldn't shake my love for
procreate which is available only for
ipad os for 10
the level of control and customization
with the apple pencil and procreate is
not only nuanced but easy to use which
for someone like me who doesn't draw
full time is very important and you can
cheat by making straight lines and
shapes which i do pretty often
you can't even draw a circle and you can
also export your procreate projects into
photoshop format and keep all your
layers
sadly procreate isn't available for
windows or android nor are there any
current plans for it to be developed for
them according to a procreate
spokeswoman i did however like
sketchable for windows which offers a
similar degree of accessibility
photoshop exporting and layered
functionality for pros adobe's 9.99 per
month photoshop is available on both the
ipad and surface pro for note takers all
the tablets include free apps apple has
notes samsung has notes
and microsoft has onenote by far the
beefiest most powerful option i prefer
goodnotes an ipad only option just
because of how easy it is to search
notes
so what should you get i would get the
apple pencil 2 and any of the new ipads
but the competition is creeping up on
apple and quick i love the microsoft
surface experience with the slim pen 2
and it's very fine and pointy tip and
the super responsive low latency sharpie
style on the s pen was awfully fun to
write with is that supposed to be a
moustache
it definitely is